I feel terrible because I have a sister
and I have a mother and I have
girlfriend also and for example if they
want to go out and have fun and if it is
if it's closing to midnight I should
call them because I am starting to worry
about them women are not second-class
actually but most men see them like that
I think wearing a skirt is important
because I think it's just a matter of
stepping out of your comfort zone and
and and doing a little bit extra to show
women that we're also by their side
behind them I mean there for them and
support them
if they are hearing us with this
interview I may say that we are just
like them and they are just like us the
open minded people who fights for their
freedom needs to sports each other